válasz jól strukturált címeket a chatek
számára én a chat gpt-t naponta többször
használom így elképzelhetitek hogy 30
nap alatt több 10 vagy akár több mint
100 különböző chatet is nyitok ilyenkor
és úgy tudom megkülönböztetni a lehető
legkönnyebben őket hogy a címüket külön
megadom át lehet nevezni egy chatet és
meg lehet adni egy chatnek konkrétan
hogy mi legyen a címe ilyenkor több
dimenzióban strukturálom sokszor
ilyenkor a címbe mint menedzser
megjelölöm hogy ez melyik projekttel
kapcsolatos vagy akár a menedzsment
pozíciómmal kapcsolatos és utána pedig
aldimenzióként megjelölöm hogy ez most
árajánlatadással volt kapcsolatos tegyük
fel vagy pedig vagy pedig egyszerűen egy
beszámolót próbálok létrehozni a jó hír
az hogy körülbelül pár nappal ezelőtt
kiadta például a chat gpt azt hogy
különböző mappa struktúrákba lehet
helyezni a chatet arra számítok hogy a
többi ai chatbot is majd követni fogja a
következő hónapban ezt a strukturálási
lehetőséget ennek ellenére egy jó
általán tipp kezdőknek is akár hogy a
címet válaszd meg te azért hogy könnyen
és gyorsan felismerd magát azt a chatet
később